hello nice to see you
let's be friends huh I'm an Arab lady
whenever people talk about the problems
facing Arab women I think it's usually
about the religion or the laws or jump
now right no one talks about the body
hair I came here to tell you about like
I grew up in a Muslim family we couldn't
talk about anything sexy like that I
just figure out on my own what was
normal for a growing girl like in high
school all the boys started saying this
phrase did you guys have this if there's
grass on the field play ball you'll have
it you can figure out what it means if
there's no put it in so I had to be like
but if the grass is too thick to move
and do they cancel the game
now one cancels the game rain or shine
finding love is hard for everybody you
know he got to put work in so my friends
were arguing to figure out like who's
put the most work in to getting a girl's
pants like I like to buy her this many
drinks right to wash her dog whatever
and then they asked me like Dena who
spent the most working to get in your
pants he's put the most work but I
thought about it and realized like
totally my gynecologist that's like 10
years of medical school
there's anyone in laughs right on
I've been deleting and reactivating
tinder for six years
you know you've had a dating profile for
too long when you start noticing
people's personal growth when you're
swiping through like oh cool
Freddie 4/20 went to grad school after
all I'm from New Jersey
my dad left when I was very young he's
lived in the Middle East my whole life
for some reason and he's a called on the
phone and giving me the same speech
every time he goes Dina I can't do an
Arab accent so just imagine your
favorite enemy of the state like Deena
you have to be a good Muslim so that one
day we can reunite together in heaven
I'm like really
you won't even reunite in New Jersey
you guys into politics
did anyone vote for Trump
it's not safe to ask I did but all I'll
vote for anyone who will keep my dad out
of the country been trying to find love
that I go on a interesting dates they
went on a date with a guy who could just
like flip everything I said - something
sexual you know he's like what kind of
music do you like I was like oh I've
been listening to the Beatles you know
that's kind of lame usually you'd do
that and you get out of it but I just
think they're cool and he said what
Beatles song would you make love to me -
huh help
[Applause]
you